>> Will Sentance: Giả sử chúng tôi có ứng dụng này lưu trữ từng người dùng trong ứng dụng của tôi
với dữ liệu tương ứng của họ.
Hãy giữ nó thực sự đơn giản.
Chúng tôi đã có nhiều dữ liệu và rất nhiều người dùng.
Giữ cho nó thực sự đơn giản, user1 tên Tim,
user2 name Stephanie, điểm 3, điểm 5.
>> Will Sentance: Chức năng tôi cần có cho mỗi người dùng, một lần nữa,
chỉ đơn giản hóa khả năng gia tăng để tăng điểm người dùng lên một,
xin lỗi, xin lỗi, người dùng điểm từng người một.
Trên thực tế, có rất nhiều chức năng ở đây.
Bây giờ, hai điều, tôi không muốn phải chạy tất cả các mã của mình hoặc
mã của tôi để thử và tìm ra chức năng gia tăng đó.
Trong thế giới lý tưởng của tôi, bất cứ nơi nào user1 ở trong
ứng dụng hiện đang được chuyển vào các phần khác nhau của ứng dụng của tôi,
Tôi có chức năng gia tăng đó ngay cạnh nó.
Và lý tưởng, bằng cách nào đó, nó được quy định khá nhiều là chỉ
áp dụng cho dữ liệu user1 hoặc cho user2 và cho dữ liệu user2 và
không đột nhiên bị cố gắng áp dụng cho bảng dẫn đầu của tôi.
Tôi sẽ cố gắng tăng bảng dẫn đầu của mình, bình thường là một điều.
Vâng, vậy làm sao tôi có thể gói gọn trong một gói trong một loại
tổ chức cấu trúc dữ liệu, dữ liệu đó với chức năng
Tôi biết rằng họ đang ở ngay cạnh nhau.
Và tôi thậm chí có thể sử dụng một đặc biệt, >> Will Sentance: Dot,
[LAUGH] chấm có lẽ để sử dụng chức năng trên dữ liệu đó.
Làm cách nào tôi có thể gói chức năng và dữ liệu ở một nơi?
Braden, bạn có ý kiến ​​gì không?
>> Loa 2: Trong vật thể hoặc xe buýt.
>> Will Sentance: Trong một đối tượng, lưu trữ trong đối tượng.
Bây giờ hãy giữ cho nó đơn giản.
Lưu trữ trong một đối tượng, điều đó chính xác.
Vì vậy, các đối tượng lưu trữ các chức năng với dữ liệu liên kết của chúng.
Điều này không được thực hiện đầy đủ trong JavaScript.
Đây là khái niệm về sự đóng gói.
Nó nói rằng hãy bảo vệ và đóng gói ở một nơi, chức năng và
dữ liệu mà nó áp dụng, dữ liệu mà nó áp dụng, ngữ pháp [KHÔNG NGHE ĐƯỢC],
dữ liệu khác mà nó áp dụng trong một gói gói nhỏ.
Và nó sẽ biến đổi cách chúng ta có thể suy luận về mã.
Nhìn này, không phải săn lùng tất cả 100.000 dòng mã của tôi,
chức năng gia tăng của tôi, tôi thực sự chỉ đặt dấu chấm và nó ở đó.
Và nó sẽ tạo ra mọi thứ mà chúng tôi cố gắng và làm ngày hôm nay,
tất cả mọi thứ chúng tôi cố gắng và làm ngày hôm nay, đạt được vị trí tối ưu của tôi.
Tất cả những gì chúng tôi cố gắng và làm ngày hôm nay chỉ là tôi có thể đạt được điều này không?
Tôi có thể đạt được chức năng chạy trên dữ liệu thích hợp không?
Không phải dữ liệu khác, không phải câu hỏi đố ngẫu nhiên, không phải bảng giải đấu ngẫu nhiên, nhưng
trên dữ liệu của người dùng và không phải đi tìm kiếm chức năng.
Nhưng nó ở ngay đó.
Tôi đặt dấu chấm và trong bảng điều khiển,
Tôi thậm chí còn thấy phần gia tăng đã được điền sẵn cho tôi, được dự đoán cho tôi.
Đó là cách dễ dàng để tìm thấy chức năng thích hợp cho dữ liệu của tôi.
Đó là mục tiêu của tôi.
Vâng, bạn biết không, tôi đã làm nó ở đây.
Tôi đã làm nó ở đây, xong.
Mô hình của tôi đã hoàn thành.
Tôi đã hoàn thành xong dữ liệu, chức năng và một đối tượng.
Nhưng chúng ta hãy tiếp tục tạo các đối tượng vì nó sẽ thành ra
rằng chúng ta sẽ rất nhanh chóng chán việc viết tay những đồ vật này.
Nhưng chúng ta hãy làm điều đó một vài lần.
Và làm như vậy,
cũng làm quen với một số cách khác nhau để tạo các đối tượng.
Mọi người có thể nghĩ ra cách khác không?
Ở đây tôi đã tạo một đối tượng, gọi nó theo nghĩa đen là đối tượng điền đầy đủ và
Tôi đã điền trước tất cả các giá trị của nó.
Tôi có thể làm gì thay thế?
Nếu tôi chỉ tạo một đối tượng rỗng, Braden,
làm thế nào tôi có thể thêm các thuộc tính vào nó sau đó?
>> Diễn giả 2: Tạo lớp.
>> Will Sentance: Không, chỉ cần giữ nó thực sự đơn giản.
Vâng, Matt?
>> Diễn giả 2: Sử dụng toán tử dấu chấm.
>> Will Sentance: Chính xác, ký hiệu dấu chấm, nó đây.
Tạo user2 với ký hiệu dấu chấm.
Khai báo các thuộc tính trống với ký hiệu dấu chấm.
Hãy đi qua.
Tôi chỉ muốn đảm bảo rằng tất cả chúng ta đều ở trên cùng một trang với sự tương tác của chúng ta
với các đối tượng.
Được rồi, Todd, dòng một ở đây, chúng ta đang lưu những gì trong bộ nhớ chung?
>> Người thuyết trình 2: Bạn đang định nghĩa khái niệm user2 là một đối tượng rỗng.
>> Will Sentance: Vâng, một vật thể trống rỗng lớn.
Đó không hẳn là một vật, chỉ là một vật rỗng.
Đây rồi, một vật thể trống rỗng to lớn, đang gán tài sản gì cho nó, Todd?
>> Người nói 2: Dòng tiếp theo chỉ định tên.
>> Will Sentance: Vâng, và gán giá trị gì cho tài sản đó?
>> Người nói 2: Mười.
>> Will Sentance: Vâng, xin lỗi, [KHÔNG NGHE ĐƯỢC], vì vậy
họ gọi những điều khác biệt này là giá trị quan trọng.
Tôi hiếm khi nghe thấy cụm từ đó trong mã chuyên nghiệp.
Chúng tôi có xu hướng gọi nó là tên thuộc tính, và sau đó là giá trị tài sản, được chứ.
Tiếp theo là điểm và 6.
Và sau đó, Matt, chúng ta đang làm gì trong slide cuối cùng ở đây?
Chúng tôi đang thêm một thuộc tính khác, vâng,
Chúng ta có xu hướng gọi các hàm trên các đối tượng là gì, Matt, mọi người?
>> Diễn giả 2: Phương pháp. >> Will Sentance: Phương pháp, vâng, tốt lắm,
chính xác, phương pháp, thực hiện tốt, dân gian.
[KHÔNG NGHE ĐƯỢC], nó đây, và đang lấy tất cả mã của nó và lưu trữ nó.
Và như thường lệ, chúng tôi không chạy mã đó nhưng
chúng tôi đang lấy toàn bộ định nghĩa hàm đó từ hàm từ sang
đóng dấu ngoặc nhọn lưu trữ trên đối tượng đó, đẹp